peut-être
alors monsieur nous annonçaient des
températures très basses et dans
l'ensemble général eh bien oui
beazer homes à 0
et la paix générale et tout le monde est
bien à langlade
il ya moins de demandes au niveau des
demandes et à 110
depuis deux ans les syndicats antigel du
languedoc
avais tu as c'est peut être cette année
nouvelle un froid tardif a mis en branle
tout l'ex positif de défense entre le
gel à lomé agriculteurs inquiets rules
attend chaque nuit à procéder à des
émissions de flux est ici quelle vision
où se trouve le plus actif le plus
important des syndicats anti gel de la
vaunage production annuelle des
viticulteurs 160 minutes pour un
veilleur a passé la nuit à la mairie et
ce matin à l'aube le téléphone a résonné
pour annoncer pour confirmer risque de
gel danger au complet et l'état major du
syndicat est venu attendre les dernières
précisions et surtout les dernières
prévisions pour lancer la date monsieur
rémy zyl président va décider cycle
alerte générale doit être donné tout
d'abord pour faire de l'émission de
fumée
bon alors je vous demande d'aller chacun
avant postes comme d'habitude et c'est
tant qu'ils ne gèlent pas vraiment à
chacun son poste voilà des jours et
après 2 minutes de la politique parce
qu'aux yeux des parents très bien
région
[Musique]
non les vignobles environnants se
couvrir d'une épaisse fumée blanche
on aura évité cette fois encore une
catastrophe
[Musique]
monsieur révisé c'est vraiment une
catastrophe lorsque le gel s'abat sur la
france a tellement c'est ici le bio tout
de la viticulture alors s'il ya danger
sinon en ruine et général alors c'est la
raison pour laquelle il faudrait la fédé
depuis quand votre syndic at il été
formés puis 18 heures environ soit près
de huit ans oui
comment fonctionne-t-il belle syndicats
cet assemblage de communes sentir qu'au
final nous vivrons uniquement dans pas
de subventions et
et c'est chaque propriétaire qui paie
encore atteint des hectares de la
récolte a fermé la cave coopérative
c'est votre seul moyen de défense c'est
le seul moyen est la plante auparavant
nous n'avions pas de fumée alors que des
tirs jolie rapidement et le batteur est
venue demander des visas les antilles et
actuels voir avec ce que nous faisons
quand même de saison des récoltes en 24
degrés par la fumée par la fumée
et quel est le rôle exact de la jouer le
rôle de la fille mais sert à atténuer
les rayons du soleil
parce que ce n'est pas la jeune et qui
grillent les bons jours c'est le soleil
quand elle arrive sur le sur les souches
qui grillent ces beaux jours alors par
l'atténuation cette fille nous arrivons
à faire monter la température
et alors il n'y a plus la rue de vesle
combien avez vous de pareilles le
deuxième en huit appareils américains et
croisés paraît il faut bien ça fait un
appareil en tout et l'origine de ces
appareils l'origine de la part
l'américain samuel des surplus ce qu'ils
ont été qu avait servi au débarquement
de la flotte américaine sur la l'algérie
et de la beauté
monsieur de carcassonne laquelle va
changer pour les services agricoles et
les missions su mais combien de temps
dure tél comment l'émission de fumée
combien de temps dure tél
le but reste tout de prendre d'intensité
de la gelée c'est par exemple à 7 heures
du matin on va traiter avant plainte
remonte on arrête
l'émission si par exemple le thermomètre
descend nous pouvons dire est facilement
jusqu'à lité en avant des besoins
d'isère et si comme ce matin par exemple
il ya du vent qu'est ce qui se passe
avec des balles arrêtées
oui parce que c'est inutile parce que c
est qu il le vend encore totalement la
figure combien coûte chaque émission de
fumée
cette émission pour toute la bande à
jojo quota minimum de 200 mille francs
retirer
[Musique]